one two three
these are precious moments for Dawn and
her young daughter Evelyn
but they hide an agonizing daily
heartbreak for families like us
where your child has been taken away
forever
you've got that hole in your life
that you will never
it'll never heal
Evelyn is a twin she and her baby
brother Archie were born at the Queen
Elizabeth the Queen Mother Hospital in
Kent
it's where baby Archie became a victim
of one of the worst maternity scandals
the country has ever seen
but he would still be alive today if he
or his mother had been given a routine
antibiotic against sepsis we
no no it was completely
avoidable
that
people weren't picking up the signs
enough
Within
um been that ill
common signs yeah that any trained nurse
or midwife
and doctors and doctors would spot
Archie was eventually rushed to St
Thomas's Hospital in London to receive
expert care
but it was too late
next to him
um
LG's hand
um and he was actually
opening his eyes
when I was talking to him and
and just felt the light is a squeeze on
my finger
um
but then from that day they said he
never opened his eyes again
it was the only time having to
go through the process of
him being taken off life support
our daughters having help him to do his
hand prints and Footprints well because
that's the only thing that we're gonna
have left
and
and it was just me and my husband in the
room
when I finally
took him off the Lost
a bit of life support
and then
me holding him was he
when
in an email seen by Sky News the trust's
chief executive Tracy Fletcher prepared
her staff to expect a harrowing report
which will have a profound and
significant impact on families and
colleagues particularly those working in
maternity services
it's expected to show how systemic
failures are the East Kent hospitals
University Foundation Trust
contributed to the deaths of dozens of
babies
just like Archie
I held a lot of guilt at the beginning
because I thought it was
partly my fault
for what happened because I was the one
carrying
the group beach trip that he first
cool
um
and I've always had with a lot of guilt
for for that
um
but
but that just grows into anger towards
the people that didn't do their jobs
that I've put this put us in this
situation
for the rest of our lives
there can be no pain like losing a child
except perhaps knowing your baby
didn't have to die Ashish Joshi Sky News
in Kent